all right joining us now former South
Carolina Governor Nikki Haley is with us
Governor great to see you how are you
you have fun out there tonight I did
have fun it was great one thing that
stood out in my mind is what a
difference between the policies of Joe
Biden and everybody on that stage one
thing you had in common there were a
couple of things that you did in this
debate that really interested me is is
you kind of went against some of the the
party's main positions on the issue of
abortion well first of all he said women
if you want something done so you really
don't trust men to do the job is that
true I'm kidding no that's a joke that
was a famous Margaret Thatcher quote
that was well said
um but on the issue of abortion I think
from a political sense I find myself in
agreement with you I look at the state
of Pennsylvania and mastriano lost by
what's nearly 16 points no exceptions
for rape incestor the mother's life and
that was political death for everyone
you know top down from that ticket as a
result of that it's an untenable
political position you know I support a
pro-life organization that gives
expecting moms free 4D ultrasounds I
just bought some ultrasound machines for
them because I believe in it however
it's a hard issue to me and when it gets
in the realm of politics it is
problematic for Republicans that they're
going to be very rigid you know and I am
unapologetically pro-life and I told
about the story of my husband and I told
about the story of my children I want to
save as many babies as we can and I want
to support as many moms as we can but I
don't judge women who are pro-choice any
more than I want them to judge me for
being pro-life so let's figure out how
we're going to support as many babies as
we can I love that it's back in the
hands of the people that's where it
should be we want that to continue to
happen but when it comes to a federal
bill I think there is a place for that
but we've got to do it where we
understand it takes 60 Senate votes and
a house majority so let's stop
demonizing the issue and let's humanize
the issue because it is personal for
every woman and every man and we have to
start talking about it that way you all
right so Donald Trump was not there and
I would think as a candidate maybe you
think okay it's an opportunity he does
take up a lot of oxygen in the room
everybody knows that
um and He commands that and obviously he
was the president you were the only
person that I heard about Chris Christie
and ASA don't count because that seems
to be their entire platform to me but
you said you don't think the party can
win with him you think Joe Biden in his
current cognitive State can beat him I
mean how sad is that but I'll tell you
so you really believe that though well
what I do believe is you're going to
have Donald Trump's going to spend more
time in a courtroom next year not
through anything outside of their
weaponizing government against him but
they're he's going to spend more time in
a courtroom than he is campaigning I
served with him I was proud to start
with him I agree with him on most issues
and he is my friend but the reality is
we cannot afford Joe box John Durham's
report said uh uh operation Crossfire
hurricane never should have been open he
also said that not one thing in the
steel dossier could be proof that was
three years of his presence okay how
much of the the charges against him do
you believe are political that it's
persecution not prosecution and it is
abuse of power and a weaponization of
our Justice it's all political it's all
weaponization all of that but the the
fact remains he's got five court cases
next year he's going to start the first
one in the early part of January he's
got another one where are you if they
can do that to one they can do it to all
it is why we have to win because we have
to make sure that this weaponization
stops it's why we have to claim the
Department of Justice is why we have to
clean house in both our intelligence
agencies it's why this matters we will
use Donald Trump as the reason we've got
to clean up Washington but you can't
clean up Washington if Donald Trump is
fighting issues of the past we need a
young generational conservative that's
going to go and clean up what they've
done to Donald Trump but also carry our
country forward Governor always great to
see you we appreciate you coming by
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else